[Musique]
combien des noms bretons de parcs
nationaux fédéraux au canada 47 leur
taille varie de 14 kilomètres carrés
pour le parc national des îles de la
baie georgienne en ontario à près de 45
mille kilomètres carrés pour celui de
wood buffalo située à cheval entre
l'alberta et territoires du nord ouest
c'est un bon en alberta que le premier
parc national du canada a été créé en
1885 chaque province et chaque
territoire possède aussi son propre
réseau de parcs
le québec a son propre réseau de parcs
nationaux
on en compte 27 le plus petit est celui
de midway chat en gaspésie qui mesure
moins d'un kilomètre carré et le plus
grand celui de tours sous diouf au
nunavik avec ses 26 mille kilomètres
carrés
s'ajoute également le parc marin du
saguenay saint laurent qui est géré
conjointement par québec et ottawa
à l'heure où la biodiversité est en
crise dans le monde un million d'espèces
sont menacées de disparition c'est park
joue un rôle crucial pour préserver les
écosystèmes le canada tout comme le
québec s'est engagé à protéger 17 % de
son territoire terrestre d'ici 2020 mais
l'objectif sera difficile à atteindre au
québec 10 % du territoire est protégé
contre près de 12 pour cent au canada